[Music]
if you want a pastrami sandwich go to
Casa de me if you want a chap to you
come to Heidi thing this my friends is
the story of the real New Yorker
sandwich and the people who keep the
legacy alive I've been teaching here for
20 years any tourist in the world enjoy
the hot doggies but all you New Yorkers
know in the chat pieces on 110th and 1st
Avenue
inside the bodega best known as Hajis we
meet Salah my name is salah el Habashi
I'm the manager of Hajis Dillon grocery
for 15 minutes we actually invent the
chap cheese your boss they get to chop
cheese where everything on it
[Music]
the ingredients is one burger for
example or two burgers you chop it up
good and you put it with some system
that's the secret the season and
whatever you like like lettuce tomatoes
onion that's Sanders is an Arabic food
what we don't add cheese over there but
when we come here we do cheese Oni on a
roll is 375 on a hero that's cost like
five dollars Hajis is located in a part
of New York that's made up of various
kinds of people with a variety of
incomes so keeping chopped cheese at a
price point everyone can afford has been
a top priority in fact the chopped
cheese has only gone up a dollar in the
last decade we are here for wrong time
helping the community and serving the
community
Geoff cheese is like everything to the
community because it's affordable and
delicious so everybody like it
you sell about 200 escapees in the
gospel if the chopped cheese is spread
beyond Harlem and into bodegas far and
wide attracting loyal New Yorkers
everywhere it appears but in the end it
all comes back to Hajis and Salah the
chap cheese every day but for me
sometimes I don't need to choose
the ketchup hamburger is the same thing
but no cheese I'm trying to lose weight
that's all
[Music]